in this video we're going to talk about
shapes
and something called angles which you
might have heard the word before so the
first question is what is an angle
well let me draw a shape and that might
help explain what an angle is so i'm
going to draw a triangle and you might
already
know that a triangle has three sides you
can see one side two sides three sides
but it also has three angles now what
are the angles well for a shape like
this you can think of an angle as where
two of the sides come together so for
example
this right over here is an angle because
two of the sides have come together
there this side and this side come
together at that point so that's an
angle
this is another angle
and that's another angle so not only
does a triangle have three sides it also
has three
angles
now let me ask you a question if i had a
rectangle
like this
how many angles
does it have
pause this video and think about it
well we can see the angles we have one
angle here another angle here so two
three
and four so not only does a rectangle
have four sides it also has four angles
now what if i were to give you another
four-sided figure another quadrilateral
quadrilateral is a very fancy word but
it really just means four-sided figure
but one that's not a rectangle what if i
were to give you something like this
so this type of a quadrilateral it still
has
four sides but you can see that it looks
a little bit different than a rectangle
all right do it so it's pretty straight
it still has one two three four sides
how many angles do we have and this
figure is called a trapezoid how many
angles does a trapezoid have
well let me count them again
so we have one angle right over here
two
three
and four
so this quadrilateral this trapezoid
like a rectangle has both four sides and
four angles
now if if i were to go the other way
around if i were to ask you draw a
figure and if you have pencil and paper
i encourage you to do it try to draw a
shape that has five
angles and see if you know the name for
that shape
all right now let's try to do this
together and let me do this in a in a
fun color well actually i'll do it in
purple
so
that is one angle right over there then
i have two angles
then i have three angles and now i have
four angles and if i meet there i get
five angles and we can see the angles
here i have one
two
three
four
five angles here you all might you also
might see that i have one
two
three
four
five sides and what do we call a
five-sided figure we call that a
pentagon
this is a pentagon right over here so
five angles and we had five sides and so
you could imagine if i had six angles
what type of a figure would it be
well i might not even draw it you could
draw it on paper if you like but if you
had six angles you're going to have a
hexagon which is a six-sided figure